Dieser Baum ist jetzt ihr Zuhause.
Wir sollen sie Sascha nennen.
Ihren Namen will uns die
21-Jährige nicht verraten,
denn sie lebt illegal auf zwölf
Metern Höhe in dieser Eiche.
Vor einem halben Jahr ist Sascha
im Hambacher Forst eingezogen.
Das Leben hier oben kann für
sie schwere Folgen haben.
Das ist ’ne Protestform,
dass wir hier leben.
Es geht nicht … also, natürlich ist es
für uns schön, auf Bäumen zu leben,
und ich genieß es total, so
verbunden zu sein mit der Natur,
aber wir machen das hier als direkte Aktion,
als Protest und nehmen in Kauf,
geräumt zu werden und sind
uns dem [dessen] bewusst.
Ich bin mir trotzdem ziemlich
sicher, dass es wehtun wird,
und find’s deswegen umso
wichtiger, dass wir zusammenhalten.
Weil es wird ja wahrscheinlich
nicht nur sein:
Wir werden hier geräumt, sondern auch:
Wir werden verhaftet und wir
kommen ins Gefängnis.
Ins Gefängnis dafür, dass sie mit ihren
Baumhäusern den Wald schützen wollen
– schützen gegen seinen Eigentümer,
den Energiekonzern RWE.
Sascha und ihre Mitstreiter haben sich
in den Bäumen professionell eingerichtet.
Sommer wie Winter leben hier
oben rund 30 Aktivisten,
um ein Zeichen zu setzen,
erklären sie uns.
Sie betrachten den Braunkohleabbau als
großes Unrecht, das sie verhindern wollen.
Nur wenige sind bereit, sich offen zu
zeigen oder mit uns zu sprechen.
Kim – links im Bild – hat sich
deshalb eine Maske aufgesetzt
und erklärt uns sein Weltbild.
Seit 40 Jahren wird hier
der Wald gerodet.
Seit 40 Jahren werden
Menschen vertrieben hier
und seit 40 Jahren wird auch die
Gesundheit und das Wohlergehen der ...
der Anwohner gefährdet durch die Emission
von der Mine, und das ist völlig legal.
Und das, was wir machen, dass wir
hier den Wald besetzt halten
und dass wir versuchen, den Wald vor der
Zerstörung zu schützen, das ist verboten.
In einem selbst gedrehten Video
dokumentieren die Besetzer
ihren Kampf um die Bäume.
Hier stürmen sie auf
Sicherheitskräfte von RWE zu,
die versuchen, ein
Baumhaus zu räumen.
Die Lage eskaliert. Die Grenzen zwischen
Protest und Gewalt sind fließend.
Der Energiekonzern
pocht auf sein Recht.
Er habe die volle politische Rückendeckung
für den Abbau der Braunkohle
in seinem Revier noch für
Jahrzehnte, sagt RWE.
Die Leute, die im Hambacher
Forst auf Bäumen sitzen,
werden dort nicht lange bleiben können,
denn der Tagebau ist genehmigt.
Klimaschutz ist ein Ziel
von Energiepolitik.
Gleichzeitig muss Energiepolitik
aber auch dafür sorgen,
dass ein dichtbesiedeltes und
hochindustrialisiertes Land
wie Deutschland zuverlässig
und auch preisgünstig,
erschwinglich mit Energie
versorgt werden kann.
Doch Braunkohle sei eine schmutzige
Energie, argumentieren Sascha und Kim.
Wenn die Bundesregierung
weiter auf sie setze,
werde sie ihre eigenen
Klimaschutzziele niemals erreichen.
Diese Mine ist hier der größte
CO2-Produzent von Europa
und das CO2 geht nicht nur uns
was an, sondern die ganze Welt.
Aber ich vertraue nicht darauf,
dass Parteien was ändern.
Und ich glaube, es ist Zeit, dass wir
unsere Zukunft selbst in die Hand nehmen.
Doch es ist ein symbolischer Kampf, denn
der größte Teil des Hambacher Forstes
ist längst abgerodet.
Der Tagebau ist ein gigantisches,
400 Meter tiefes Loch,
das in den letzten Jahrzehnten
nicht nur den Wald,
sondern bereits zahlreiche
Ortschaften verschlungen hat.
Tausende Menschen mussten
umgesiedelt werden.
Bisher konnten weder Klagen noch
das Engagement der Aktivisten
am Ende die Braunkohlebagger stoppen.
Erst 2050 will die Bundesregierung
aus der Braunkohle aussteigen.
Trotzdem wollen Sascha und
Kim nicht aufgeben.
Für sie geht es nicht nur
um den Braunkohleabbau.
Ihr Ziel ist es, gegen
Ausbeutung zu kämpfen
– Ausbeutung von Mensch und Natur.
Beides symbolisiere der
Hambacher Forst.
Man hat einmal diesen
wunderschönen Wald hier, der …
wo alles lebt und wo alles grün ist
und irgendwie harmonisch ist noch.
Und daneben hat man die Mine.
Das ist einfach ’n unglaubliches Nichts,
das ist … das ist tot.
Das ist für mich ’n total guter
Ausgangspunkt für ’n Kampf,
der sich gegen viel mehr richtet.
Ein Kampf auf Zeit:
Die Sicherheitskräfte von RWE beobachten
alles, was am und im Wald passiert.
Sascha rechnet damit, dass auch ihr
Baumhaus bald geräumt werden könnte.
Doch darauf seien sie und
die anderen vorbereitet.